he's Bruce Bowen he won three
championships with the Spurs and worked
at the mothership former Clippers TV
analyst and kind enough to join us now
Bruce good morning how are you I'm doing
okay before I get to the Clippers
situation let me ask you about what
daryl morey had to say yesterday on our
show where he said that he thinks LeBron
is the best player of all time by a bit
of a wide margin there and he said he
was basing this on analytics what
analytics do you think he could be using
that he would have LeBron is the
greatest player of all time I mean the
consecutive Finals appearances that adds
to the whole process of what you know
he's coming up with but I think more
than anything else then is that we live
in a different society today as far as
how basketball is necessarily talked
about scouted and things of that nature
it's not to take away from the analytics
because it is helpful but I came up
under a different style of basketball I
came up under that somebody went out and
scouted you and watch the guys against
certain guys and saw what they can do
against the best as well as the worst
and now you have such advanced scouting
you have computers involved and so when
you have that now the computer can't see
that say for example a backup guard has
a +10 type of point production
throughout the season and that starter
who averages 30 minutes a game maybe
have a -3 but what they don't understand
is that when that backup gar goes into
blowout it's really no pressure on him
so it's really hard to determine
necessarily certain outputs of play as
compared to when you allow the computer
to do it because the computer can't
sense the moments per se as well as
people could but you also have to look
at the generation deal a lot the kids
today all I know of Michael Jordan is
Space Jam and that he has cool shoes no
one knows that he was the bar he was the
bar as far as you want to be the best
you want to be the go-to guy because of
what he did but guys like LeBron James
Kobe Bryant so for those guys study what
MJ did and eight
a little bit of what MJ had and now I've
incorporated into their game better
all-around player I think is more of the
argument because I think you know
Michael has the better resume and
LeBrons not done yet but you played
against both of these guys if you were
just assessing basketball talents who
was a better basketball talent Bronner
MJ the talent coming into the game it
was it was LeBron I mean he Dan he saw
the floor so well and that still his
string but he came in equipped whereas
Michael Jordan came into the game
Michael Jordan couldn't shoot the ball
or dribble and that's what people don't
realize is that he was such a relentless
worker at trying to be the best at his
craft you know I go back to the story of
what Kenny Kenny Smith shared with me as
far as you know at pickup basketball he
wants to set the tone even in college
where when they won their game everybody
else went to go get water Michael stayed
on the floor and that's more about a
mental toughness and allowing Kai's to
understand that hey no I don't need
water to do what I'm gonna do to you
right now because I'm setting the tone
as far as who I am and what I'm going to
be you know so with that that thought
process not coming in as the best
already the work is what what transpired
to what we've seen in the six
championships with MJ he didn't have all
the tools in but I tell you this he sure
didn't finish with a lot of those two
that everyone tends to look at and try
to take a piece of now LeBron I'm amazed
at what he's still doing today Dan
because it is truly about the love of
the game for him he loves the game of
basketball when you love something
you're willing to keep your body in
tip-top shape year round not taking any
time off there are some guys I was at
this Nike Elite Academy last week and
LeBron came through playing with the top
25 high school kids top 25 college kids
and he it looked like he hadn't missed a
beat now some of the other NBA players
that came in and played they didn't have
their physique looking like LeBrons
because I think some of those guys took
some time off and they used this time
now to try to get back into shape
can you have an open mind that LeBron
could end up as the greatest of all time
it's hard for me to say the greatest of
all time because of the error I played
in of what I grew up watching I think
that's what it's that's what you know I
go with and you know I had this
discussion with someone else one time
you know Robert Horry play with it came
Olajuwon and he thinks the world of a
king but he played with them I played
with Tim Duncan and I think the world of
Tim Duncan as far as greatest players
now law on the Block it's hard for me to
say that LeBron would be the greatest
ever play because of what I grew up
singing Michael what I grew up trying to
be like you know it was a short time I
tried to be like you know high school
you know but you know with LeBron is I
mean he he's changed the game as far as
how big he is six nine to sixty moving
like a point guard no I I can say that
he's the he's the best right now as you
know how even you got you can't limit
Kobe and what he was able to do so it's
not just about two guys as far as I'm
concerned Dan it's a multiple uh it's
multiple players tougher to guard Kobe
or LeBron you would ask that question I
think I think Kobe was was the toughest
to guard for me because at that time you
got to realize when the Bron played
against me in the finals he was not who
he is now he's definitely improved but
Kobe's Kobe was such a competitor that
that even if they were if they were down
20 very rarely did he just catch the
ball and swing it to the other side he
was still in the mode of how can I get
on a roll real quick to help my
teammates and the fact that he stopped
eating certain that he changed his diet
at 25 years of age you know guys don't
usually do that until they start seeing
the put around their gut but but again
this is a student of the game somebody
who loved the game of basketball that
ate drank and slept basketball
this is why he was so special as a
player and you know had a chance to see
him last weekend and it was just funny
two bald guys with beards that are now
talking about their kids as we Coast
them would you be surprised if Kobe
decided he wanted to play like came out
of retirement want to play for the
Lakers oh absolutely
I'd definitely be surprised at that
because you know it's one of those deals
for him is he's done it he's his body I
mean think about this and Achilles tears
surgeries broken fingers you know pull
joints it's just and I after Wow Dan as
much as your mind say I think you can
your body says what are you doing down
somewhere we're talking to Bruce Bowen
three-time NBA champ with the Spurs and
up until recently the Clippers TV
analyst I had helped me understand this
why you don't have a job with the
Clippers now Bruce I you know it's it's
just the way it is I guess sometimes the
business of basketball it can go a
certain way and know this isn't the way
it is this is this is unique you're good
at what you do did you get fired or not
brought back because of what you said
about Kawhi Leonard and that is gonna
somehow poison the water of giving you
know allowing the Clippers to have a
chance to bring in Kawhi Leonard it was
it was because of my comments towards
Kawhi what I had to say about him now
now the thing is Kawhi and it's family
I'm very good with but you know I feel
like this that as a analyst as a former
player as a guy that that used to talk
to the kawar a lot I think is important
that I can say the truth and be able to
face his mother you know I'm not tearing
them down but I am talking about the way
you go about things expressly in today's
society where so many things are just
let go and no one tends to talk about
what's truly going on and you know for a
young man to
have the world at his feet here in San
Antonio
you know the team was built around him I
think sometimes when you're constantly
watching others or somebody in your camp
is feeling like you would be better off
somewhere else I don't ever think that's
the right right idea you know the whole
thing of you know you think the grass is
greener on the other side just take a
water hose out and water your own grass
to emulate what you see now who's to say
that he's going to have a community a
team or say an organization that's
behind him quite like when he had it
here in San Antonio those are the things
and when people talk about how great of
a player he is yes it shows on the floor
but what is the next person thinking
about if this guy has chosen not to go
to a playoff game with his teammates
because he's working out in New York and
your team is in Golden State those were
my thoughts as far as how this takes
place because I played with some great
players and you know for Tim Duncan as
far as being the greatest spur of
all-time to his last season he finished
the game on the floor because of his
love and dedication to the game there is
no way that you can say without you know
having some type of a doubt that I would
want to be in a bunker with Kawhi when
he doesn't want to support his teammates
now you get in that bunker with town
Duncan because you know he's there and
if your go-to guy this is what's
required but let me go back to the clip
how did what did the Clippers say to you
did they come out and just say look
we're not bringing you back because the
comments you made about Kawhi was it
that kind of cut and dry oh yeah it was
well basically we don't view your views
that way and because of your comments of
Kawhi Leonard who chose to go a separate
way who told you that a an individual
within their organization who who signed
off on me being on board yeah it's just
bizarre I mean because I was told by
somebody
who's with the Clippers who said look
we're not taking any chances here we
can't you know and I thought man you're
gonna fire Bruce Bowen because he was
honest about Kauai and therefore kawaii
might not want to play for the Clippers
is that really what this is all about
one thing that I thought about in all of
this is that Kauai never said I want to
play for the Clippers
Kauai said he wanted to play for the
Lakers yeah and so you know
unfortunately if you're going to run
your organization based on hopes maybe
and and and getting rid of others now if
I again if I tore him down and I was
disrespectful to him that's one thing
but that's not the case as an analyst
I'm supposed to talk about what I see
and what I feel for this game that I
love and so if you can't do that what
does that say about your organization
can you would you build a team around
Kawhi Leonard if you were a GM no I
would not
and and I say that from what has
transpired now okay
you know it now if you would ask me that
two years ago I say absolutely that's
what you do you had talking about a
Finals MVP and he's had a very he had it
very good as far as having Tim Tony and
Manu to kind of learn from and then you
go from there
but only because of the actions that
I've seen here of late would it create
doubt for me to build around Kawhi do
you think use paper not a flat to him
it's just the fact that this is what
I've seen from you and and I just don't
have that trust that I can feel that way
about you going into something specials
for the season or playoff series do you
think that kawaii or his people had
anything to do with this I think you
know until Kawhi comes out and says
something he's gonna be the he's gonna
be the person that everyone will say
well why didn't he say something you
know if Kawhi came out and said these
things and and and not no one else but
if Kawhi says it then at least you say
okay
we got it from the horse's mouth but
nobody now
job you losing your job do you think
that quas camp had anything that is you
know did they give the Clippers a hey
you know what you know we can't have
this if you want me to consider the
Clippers you can't have somebody who's
gonna be ripping me you know I don't
think they're that I don't think I'm
that I'm that powerful where you know I
would be the reason why someone would
not want to go to a team I mean it's
what are you doing are you plan are you
listening what and if you are listening
then listen to the words that are said
and and receive the constructive
criticism because that's my job to be
critical of someone's play now if I'm
just tearing a player down that's one
thing but I don't think I'm big enough
that someone would say you know what I'm
not going there because Bruce Boeing is
there any any and he's on the mic I'm
not going to deal with that because I'm
the same person that's just going to
call it how it is you go for ten free
you go ten for fifteen I'm gonna talk
about how you utilizing jazz stuff
setting your guy up to come off a screen
and getting down in a defensive position
to get steals now if I'm if I'm praising
you but I also have to be honest as well
because there are listeners out there to
see to see what I'm saying is it just a
homer or is this someone that's telling
the truth about the game that he loves
well I think the difference is and you
found this out the hard way you can be
critical do your job as an analyst on
ESPN but you can't do that in a local
market you know I think that that's
that's the big difference you know
you're supposed to be I was told that
Bruce knows that he's supposed to be a
homer
we shouldn't be talking about Kawhi
because he knows that we would like to
get Kawhi we can't get free agents here
and these kind of comments you know can
only do damage to that that possibility
so if you can't get free agents in
California in Los Angeles that is that
has nothing to do with Bruce Bowen that
has more to do with the organization you
can drop the mic on that one Bruce thank
you Bruce we'll check in with you during
this season unless you get another job
and then you know you know you might be
busy but yours for quite some time and
even when you were at the mothership I
you know I just don't critique me here
because then I probably is I'm not gonna
be able to have you on okay Bruce that's
a Bruce Bowen three-time NBA champ of
the Spurs and the former clippers TV
analyst for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]